la parole est à madame catherine
tremblay pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
najat vallaud belkacem ministre de
l'éducation nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
madame la ministre il ya deux jours
sortait un rapport de la cour des
comptes qui pointait le surcoût tu du
lycée français nous dépensons 38% de
plus pour notre lycée par rapport à nos
voisins et dans le même temps nous
dépensons 20% de moi pour notre
enseignement primaire nous concentrons
nos moyens un moment de la scolarité ou
l'échec scolaire est tellement enracinée
qui n'est plus résorbables c'est à
l'école maternelle et à l'école
élémentaire que les élèves apprennent à
lire à écrire à compter
ce n'est pas au lycée c'est sur l'école
primaire que nous devons concentrer nos
moyens
l'enseignement primaire doit être la
priorité dans le cadre de la refondation
de l'école mais la vérité c'est que sur
les quelques postes d'enseignants
réellement créé vous en avez créé plus
dans le secondaire que dans le primaire
vous n'atteindrez pas les objectifs de
près scolarisation des enfants de moins
de 3 ans que vous avez fixé avec une
diminution massive des dotations de
l'état les collectivités ne pourront pas
investir pour accueillir ces enfants
vous avez réformer les programmes la
maternelle mais votre administration ne
s'est jamais demandé si les méthodes
d'enseignement de la lecture mis à
disposition des enseignants ne
conduisait pas à produire de
l'illettrisme et de l'échec scolaire
enfin madame votre gouvernement a
augmenté de 4 milliards le budget de
l'éducation nationale
autant en moins pour la défense et pour
la protection sociale vous avez préféré
faire appel au portefeuille des français
sans vous demander si les centaines
d'options proposées au lycée de
constituer pas une source importante
d'économies ma question est très simple
madame la ministre
quel est l'objectif poursuivi par la
politique d'éducation du gouvernement en
fait quelle est sa cohérence madame la
ministre
merci la parole est au ministre de
l'éducation nationale mme najat vallaud
belkacem
merci monsieur l'asie
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice catherine promener
j'ai fait un rêve
oui vous voyez en prendre la parole sur
l'éducation j'ai fait le rêve que en ce
début d'année scolaire vous commenceriez
peut-être votre question par souligner
que la rentrée scolaire c'était fort
bien passer partout sur le territoire y
compris dans votre département
mais c'était sans doute trop vous
demander et donc je déduis de votre
question aujourd'hui que sur ses bancs
de l'assemblée on n'a pas encore pris
l'engagement des bonnes résolutions de
ce début d'année scolaire c'est dommage
de mon côté j'en ai prises des bonnes
résolutions notamment celle de la
pédagogie donc je vais vous répondre en
détail
pour vous ré expliquer et peut-être que
cela vous aidera enfin à comprendre en
quoi les réformes que nous conduisons
depuis 2012 ont conduit à cette rentrée
scolaire qui s'est bien passé oui
recréer des postes dans l'éducation
nationale je précise que nous en sommes
à 35 mille deux cents postes recréer est
utile en effet pour avoir un enseignant
dans chaque salle de classe voire plus
d'enseignants que de classe puisque nous
avons plus de maîtres queux de classe à
l'école primaire
oui avoir remis la formation initiale
que vous aviez eu l'inepte idée de
supprimer pour les enseignants ça aide à
avoir des enseignants mieux formés oui
la refondation de l'école que vous avez
adopté ici en 2013 a commencé comme le
dit son nom refondation c'est commencer
par les bases par les fondements par
l'école primaire même par l'école
maternelle est d'ailleurs l'école
maternelle cette année fait l'objet de
nouveaux programmes de scolarité qui
sont plébiscités par les enseignants eux
mêmes
oui l'ensemble de la scolarité
obligatoire des élèves est désormais
revu avec de nouveaux programmes que
j'ai présenté récemment une nouvelle
évaluation un collège qui verra le jour
à partir de la rentrée prochaine
je crois qu'on ne peut vraiment pas
faire le reproche à ce gouvernement
d'avoir sous traiter ou maltraitées
l'éducation bien au contraire mais vous
évoquez le livre sur leur contrainte
rang de l'est
lycée je vous rappelle que c'est votre
réforme qui est mise en cause par la
cour des comptes celle de 2010 celle qui
a conduit en effet avoir un lycée à ces
insatisfaisant dont nous allons tirer le
bilan et nous verrons en effet comment
intégrer les remarques de la cour des
comptes
pour quelques secondes
madame la ministre je ne suis pas une
élève face à une prof en ce qui concerne
la rentrée scolaire vous êtes dans un
déni total
je vous invite à plus de lucidité et
plus de pragmatisme
merci